est-ce que vous avez des questions pour
booba j'aimerais que vous me posez
choqué alors on sait que bon vous avez
un tempérament de feu si elle un
tempérament de feu
est-ce que jamais une fois entre vos
deux il ya eu un peu de courant un peu
de soleil et un peu de on se cherche à
bois partageons l'animal quand même
brook avec les congés maladie pas mal
non mais je vous jure il ya eu un truc
con ce qu on va pas chez moi je veux un
truc avec booba parce que je sais pas
j'ai l'impression qu'ils pensent comme
moi c'est à chaque fois ni même parfois
il s'embrouille avec des mecs jeu
je comprends ce soir ce à quoi c'est à
dire qu'il ya aussi je le dis booba il a
lancé énormément de mecs giuly il a
dansé énormément de gars et y en a peu
des mecs comme lui qui ont lancé des
gens et je le dis en télé et benjamin tu
étais déjà plein de mecs aussi et quand
les mecs sont pas reconnaissants à
servir m6 a rien de pire et est aussi il
ya plein de gars comme ça où des mecs
voilà tu les as surtout quand ils sont
pas reconnaissants et qui en plus si tu
attaques assez ça donnait faut c'est
défendre quoi mais c'est normal mais si
sarah moi j'essaie mais de quelqu'un de
juste
aussi je pense on a des bosseurs donc la
trahison on l'a vu encore plus mal mais
c'est ça et souvent on peut on croit que
c'est nous qui attaquons les mecs je
jure que c'est vrai et 99% du temps on
fait que répondre si je peux me
permettre vous aimez ça beaucoup tous
les deux aussi vous aimez au monde
chacun mais oui je sais ça con c'est
parti c'est parti ouais ouais c'est ça
tu cherches tu trouves ça à partir de à
partir du moment où tu te mets en
compétition contre moi faut qu'il y en
ait un qui reste au sol c'est sa durée
ça un jour tu m'as dit un truc on était
au téléphone dans son cher je suis venu
en survêtement parce que j'ai vu la
bagarre at je t'en parle pas mais j'ai
vu la bagarre caisse à baguer les
bagarres moi je suis victime d'une
bagarre bombe à jour tu m'as dit hôtel
tu m'as dit tous les deux ont des nos
positions sama et gérer plus humaniste
ni c'est vrai il a raison en fait tiré
que la résistance
c'est fait c'est sale et il est à la
piraterie tout ça c'est quoi pour toi
c'est la résistance la liberté un peu
ouais on va pas se plier à chaque règle
y adhérer conques un sens mais vous est
arrivé parvenez à quelqu'un ouais ça
dépend le niveau de nom fait très
exactement
il ya un niveau il n'ya plus de retour
genre les caristes ce n'est pas deux
ouais tiens justement je crois qu'à une
question sur carrie seidel site oui oui
moi ma question c'est ça qu'est ce que
de caris pourrait faire pour que vous
fassiez enfin la paix parce que là vous
allez partir enfin vous allez vous allez
changer de vie plus ou moins qu'est ce
qui pourrait faire pour que vous partiez
un peu apaisées il a fini par faire ya
pas de paix à faire
ok c'est quoi la vie oui bernard monter
vous rappelez quand vous étiez venu à
dernière fois skb quand on avait reçu
caris & vous étiez au téléphone
est ce qu'il y avait vraiment sa grand
mère dans la salle de gym en suisse ubs
s'est pas déjugé aubin en 5 dès jeudi
qu'elles avaient un 5b même j'ai
commencé dans une émission télé est ce
que vous accepteriez par exemple puisque
maintenant vous allez aussi produire et
vous avez déjà produit plein de gens
très talentueux d'être jurée dans the
voice par exemple si on vous proposait
bad 11 voix il se met deux peut-être
faire une émission à moi dans le genre
bah ouais pas dangereux cherchent une
chaîne à producteurs en france
mais voilà maintenant mais j'avais ce
projet là avant qu est donc match c'est
sur canal + sur ses boys mais là encore
un peu
ouais mais qu'au rap ou pas ça c'est
bien normalement toutes musiques
confondues pour canal plus ce serait nom
n'apparaîtrait dedans bah oui sinon il
faut signer un petit truc un accord de
principe à une exclu une exclu
d'abaisser ce serait intéressant mais je
pense que ce serait très fort et je te
dis pour canal plus ce serait un beau
projet parce que canal+ typiquement
c'est une chaîne où on doit pas boire on
doit voir des trucs qu'on voit pas
ailleurs aratoires booba on doit le voir
que sur canal+ pour moi en france voilà
après s'il fait d'autres trucs a libéré
en france et c'est canal+ kelly alors
vous êtes assez discret sur votre vie
privée sentimentale etc
on connaît vos rapports dans la musique
avec les femmes que ce soit dans les
clips ou dans les sons quels sont vos
rapports en privé et dans l'intimité
d'une position rêvée avec les femmes
comme tout le monde je comprends pas la
question est ce que j'ai des relations
non non non non c'est dans vos clips et
d'envoi sont bas les femmes c'est gros
cul grosses fesses on les tartines
donc est-ce que c'est pareil aucune
grosse façon les tartines beurrées les
femmes en privé c'est ça mais je vous
respecte les femmes ouais c'est vrai je
respecte la vie en général comme plantes
animaux tous et moi je vous ai dit oui
et on a mitigé en multi perfido moi je
suis je suis entier c'est ça je suis
sincère je suis est simple en fait
non mais c'est vrai et voilà qu'on ya un
gars voilà quand éric un gâteau avec lui
tu étais ses tongs abri de la chaleur
c'est pour ça que je supporte encore
moins la trahison c'est ça c'est mes
gonds pour moi un des spectateurs c'est
vrai la taille vous avez souvent mis
l'argent en avant dans vos clips
pouvez vous nous dire à combien s'estime
maintenant votre
votre fortune aujourd'hui s'attarder
vraie question est la deuxième nation
est ce que tu penses qu'on peut me faire
un pot commun par les deux maires selon
vous qui est le meilleur rappeur
français aujourd'hui et qui est le pire
le meilleur de sa génération je dirais
que c'est niño ok on embrasse le berry
rien n'a trop rien dire si tu dois
sortir karan ou un ouais celui qu'on y
passe bien on tenait à sa se fait pas
celui du moment où je sais pas julie
flinguer sa carrière c'est vrai ben
ouais ouais franchement at-il sur la
retraite j'ai essayé de partir en
douceur arrête n'est pas la retraite du
tout mais on aggravera quand tu dis ça
quel dommage déjà y avait payé le
dixième album qui sort ce soir à minuit
et je t'explique là déjà ça va être
on s'arrête un carton tu le sais je
pense t il travailler pour en tout cas
ouais je suis satisfait je suis soulagée
j'ai fait le boulot mais ce que ça veut
dire que je suis entendre est plus que
jamais un nouveau type de droit sur un
album je peux de youn est un single hot
et ça rend voilà on m'a dit que je forme
album met la presse à caen etc
c'est terminé manning n 20 singles
pendant votre carrière vous avez
multiplié les clashs skis à quelqu'un
que vous n'avez pas clasher et que vous
regrettez multiplié les collaborations
aussi parce que bien sûr collaboration
atlas a fait plus de bruit qu'autre
chose
vous avez aussi allumé beaucoup
d'artistes récemment dans des articles
j'ai pas tous ceux retenus
mais quand vous le faites c'est parce
que vous avez fait quelque chose que
vous n'aimez pas ce qu'ils font les deux
sauts de pont s'il en a qui m'insupporte
je peux le dire parce que d'un point de
vue professionnel sur moi et vous ont
répondu
bon certains années pendant lesquelles